[Applause]
all right we have uh leah nimmin tyler
how are you we are great how are you
good i'm happy to be here i like you're
excited cheetah skirt thank you
exchange it for the sweatpants just for
you all right what's it gonna be a truth
or a dare a truth please okay hit us
okay
i want to ask if you could be invisible
what's the first thing that you would do
oh
okay well all i was going to do was go
on a date with kim kardashian and pete
davidson to get what's really going on i
really want to
that's
just so much better
is that a good one oh gosh now i feel
okay oh gosh um okay i'm invisible yeah
what are you doing um what do you want
to do all i keep thinking about is food
that's my bad one sneak into like a dim
sum kitchen uh-huh and just like
full just steal all the dim stuff that's
that's weird no that's good you bring me
home the dim sum and i'll give you the
scoop on kim k and pete i'll bring some
dumplings and you can tell me all about
kim kmp girl i will tell you everything
okay
all right well thank you everybody so
much for joining us today and choosing
to spend your time with us because we
make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]
you